let's talk about entrepreneurship and
setting the groundwork for this because
it's it's not
a easy thing I think it's a simple thing
once you get it right and you understand
what's involved and how to engineer it
because you can engineer a good business
like most
people by default do it wrong just like
by default happy wife happy life you
know you hear the vows riches and and
sickness health and poor and doesn't
matter she's always gonna stick around
don't don't even sweat it she's not
going anywhere just say I do and sign
over here and walk around the table and
do your reception and it's good boys
right and you know just like with
relationships and the red pilling that
we get there with whatever it happens to
be she steps out you know she like the
whole love into perpetuity doesn't exist
and then you have this Awakening I think
a lot of people when it comes to
starting up a business for themselves
at some point have this Grand Awakening
because the illusion of I'm going to be
a big boss and be an entrepreneur and
run this Corporation and here's my
business cards with my name on it it
says president and CEO just underneath
there and you feel Grand and special the
vast majority of businesses out there
that start will never break more than a
million dollars a year in annual sales
the number is something like
97% so the vast majority of people out
there that are holding out to the public
that they're an entrepreneur I'm not
saying they're not but the vast majority
of them are not cracking more than a
million dollars in annual sales um
they're mom and pop shops they you know
your dry cleaners you know at the corner
you're the you know the corner store
that's doing nail salon stuff you know
like the
standard simplistic conventional cookie
cutter thing that we've always been told
to do like when my granddad in England
retired from the Royal Air Force you
know the first thing he did was he he
was like right I want to go and become
an entrepreneur you know what he did he
did what everybody else did he went and
opened up a pub right because that's
because that's the path to riches and he
found out it was long hours for not a
lot of money and a whole lot of headache
right so this is the path that most
people choose is something that seems
common oh I can set up an e-com store
and I can move [__] right like all I got
to do is find it for cheap in China go
to Alibaba buy a a crate a shipping
container or whatever uh the of the
niche the product that I want to sell
I'll do Amazon FBA which is fulfilled by
Amazon I put my [__] in their warehouse
I do my ads I do my paid advertising uh
people click they buy and then the
profit rolls in and that sounds simple
and easy oh you just have to do the
research on the right the right topic
you know you have to do the research on
the right product and make sure you
angle it right and you twist it sort of
this way and it's
like it can work for a few months
sometimes the problem when you build
your business on somebody else's
platform like Amazon is you very quickly
learn that it's not stable you rely on
the algorithms when people search for
things showing your product and if your
product's a hot seller anybody can come
in and undercut including Amazon white
label some [__] and compete against it
and suppress you in the algorithms and
you go looking for other Solutions oh
let's go to Shopify we'll build a
Shopify store and then we'll Market it
on Facebook and uh Instagram and YouTube
pre-roll ads and all that sort of stuff
and it's like okay that's another way to
do it right but then that starts eating
into the profit margins oh and by the
way you're moving a physical product and
what happens when you move a physical
product [__] gets lost in the mail it
gets broken people receive it they lie
and they say they never got it and you
have to reship another one there's
returns
so eliminating the potential and the
possibility
for chaos and headache in your business
can be engineered from the GetGo you
know it's the point that I'm making so
I'm just using Amazon FBA just as one
example right there's lots of other
things out there that you hear all the
time that you know they're on social
media oh if you sign up for my program
or my University or some [__] like this
uh and go and do copywriting or video
editing or any version of any of those
things you'll become vastly wealthy and
influential and you know women will be
throwing themselves at you right doesn't
work that way my my emails are filled
till this day and I keep mentioning this
year-over year it's been happening for
the last few years because it's been
normalized it's been pumped out in the
public so much now everybody's a [__]
video editor everybody you know what I
pay for edited reals like 20 bucks
that's it that's with captions with
music upload everything right because
there's somebody in Indonesia that's
willing to do that for next to nothing
it's not a path to riches or wealth
right it's it's a path out of poverty
maybe in that country where you can make
a pretty decent living but you're not
going to be rolling around in a Lambo
right like you're gonna pay some bills
right like it'll be fine copywriting is
another one too emails blowing up all
the time let me do my copywriting they
DM me it's like they all have these
creative like ways to sort of try to get
your attention but you're one of a
couple of dozen every single day seven
days a week 30 days a month you know 12
months of the like you know it it adds
up and you're competing for the
attention of entrepreneurs which for the
most part like guys like me I write my
own copy right like I'll do my own
emails so if you get on my email list
and you get an email it's from me so
back to the uh you know paths to to
wealth when it comes to becoming an
entrepreneur um what other examp like
you guys tell me what you can think of
in the chat that is a potential path to
wealth right you know you get guys that
say that they're in the weed Business
Like I Do 420 okay so let's say that
you're in the Cannabis business or the
CBD business or you're a grower or
you're or you're a distributor right uh
here anyway in Canada if you get the
license to open up a dispensary then
you've got to have a physical storefront
with signage with rent you know license
agreements and I know guys that are in
the space they got in the space early
before the licenses were handed out like
candy uh and you had to jump through
legislative Hoops to get them and there
were so few that were available they
actually made money but now again the
markets become saturated so I don't know
where James is that that does you know
like 420 or whatever that is but um for
the most part again moving a physical
product you have to have storefront you
have to have Regulators up your ass
about everything these are things that
you can engineer into a business that
you can avoid
right Chris says I told certain instit
institutional clients to kick rocks when
they said they needed our
jobs we when they said we needed our
jobs to do their work I think that's
Jabs I still won't touch the work
regardless of value see that's when
you're in a position to say no right
like that's ideally what
entrepreneurship should get you to is a
position of Fu not just Fu to you know
point at people and say FU but Fu as an
Fu money so you don't need to take jobs
you don't need to do or perform tasks
because of that
um what else we got in
here considering opening own practice as
CPA your thoughts so anything to do with
accounting is a
service one of the downsides to working
as accountant one it's it's it's not the
most unless you really love numbers and
reconciling columns and stuff like that
it's not the most
interesting line of work or business
excuse me
I mean I've been fortunate enough to
have some cool accountants and I select
accountants to work with that I want to
sit down and have lunch with if I don't
Jive we're not doing business so again
you know things with professional
designation like you know we're talking
earlier about you can make a good amount
of money if you're a license accountant
he's saying should I open up my own
practice so
versus being a accountant that's
licensed to work in an office as an
employee versus being the employer and
employing other people to work for you
you have to take on the task of
marketing acquiring clients customer
service you got to procure uh space uh
licensing
dues um you need Eno Insurance errors
and admission um in case you ever get
sued um you're probably going to have a
lawyer on retain coner running your own
business and it's location dependent to
a certain region which I'm not a big fan
of right because again if something
happens and you want to pick up your
business and just go somewhere else you
can go to another country you can get a
starlink and drive an RV around North
and South America if you want and do
your business that way you can be on a
sailboat in the middle of the ocean with
a starlink and do your business that way
I'm not a big fan of location dependent
businesses which keep you anchor to a
certain local right because then you're
stuck there right like you've set down
Roots you want to get up and go
somewhere else it's not always plausible
right legislation and rules can change
in the jurisdiction that you're licensed
are work in that aren't favorable which
I saw happen here in my debt business
between 2010 and
2013 right I've talked about that before
so is it a easy lucrative and fun
business opening up a practice as a CPA
no I would would say no it's
not let me scroll through a few more of
these see what you guys are on about
here again if you have any questions or
examples that you want me to touch on
what do you think about a bookkeeping
business another good question that's
another business that's location
dependent requires you to Market to
people to get their business it's a low
billable rate um bookkeepers here 90 to
110 bucks an hour you know maybe 80 on
the lower end if they're Junior if they
work from their own home um it's a time
for money job right so if you can only
bill $80 an hour for
example and um you've only got three or
four hours of work one day then what are
you doing the rest of the time you're
gonna smoo you're gonna have to try to
find some business you're gonna have to
try to find some clients and even if
you're maxed out fully you know
throughout the day right like let's say
that you're fully maxed out you're doing
80 hours
right that's $6,400 per pay period
right sorry let's go
6,400 times uh 26 weeks because that's
usually standard so that's
$166,000 a year so if you're a
bookkeeper fully
booked okay 80 hour work weeks bi-weekly
for an entire year the maximum you're
ever going to earn is
$166,000 that's it now you're going to
have to take away your expenses to run
that business you might be left with
$100,000 you might actually arguably be
better off working for somebody getting
paid $100,000 so you don't have to deal
with a headache of all the other
[__] because like the max cap you're
going to make is $166 $400 right
$166,400
so I'm not a big fan of trading time for
money at a low rate look if you're a
very successful lawyer and you're
bilding yourself out at $1,000 an hour
um cool that's way better than 80 or or
110 right
uh it's still going to cap you right
like let's take a lawyer that bills
himself out $1,000 an
hour that's $80,000 time
26 that's
2.08 million you're doing real well
you're doing real real well but you're
working all the [__] time doing law
which honestly I would rather gouge my
eyeballs out than read all that
[__] see what else we got
here human beings are the worst part of
a business so that's the other thing too
right you can engineer a business that
doesn't require
employees I've employed a lot of people
okay in this business and in the
corporations that I worked for prior to
that I've employed or terminated
hundreds and hundreds of people right
there's flaws with human beings there's
a reason why McDonald's is now opening
up fully automated McDonald outlets now
that are open 247 the robots cook
everything perfectly every single time
delivered faster than any human being
can flip a burger or drop fries into a
tray it's it's it's a process in a
system that is far more profitable for
them because they don't have to deal
with an employee that calls in sick
doesn't show up has to take Matt leave
they're banging other employees in the
back room and HR has to get involved and
all of a sudden Karen's yelling at
somebody there's none of these
problems that that exist in an
environment where you don't have a human
being working as an employee and that
takes the humans out of the equation I
think you're going to see um you know
things like Universal basic income kick
off and you know become a lot more
popular you're going to be seeing people
getting like a a base stable like living
I'm not going to call it a wage but a
living donation monthly from the
government because let's be honest I
mean they just print money so who
[__] cares right like it's just the
way the government operates now
so you're going to see a lot of these
low-level things automate or Outsource
or made obsolete you know if anything
and having employees is something that
you can engineer into a business or you
can engineer out of the business um the
kinds of businesses that I talk about in
my course in the School of
Entrepreneurship are what are defined as
easy lucrative and fun and they're
usually either service or information
based so there's no products to move or
sell or stock in a warehouse or return
or get broken or get lost or any of that
[__] so it's either a service type
of business or it's an information type
of business it's location independent
meaning you don't have to have a
storefront with a neon sign and a door
that's locked and unlock with store
hours in the front or any of that [__]
it's not it's never going to have to
comply with stand on this dot whereare
face dier or take this experimental jab
because it's location independent and it
sells a service or information and you
also generally don't need employees you
might need some contractors to do some
work I've I've got some contractors that
do work for me but I don't have any
salaried employees that are ever going
to you know well let me talk to HR
because you know Becky was mean to me
today [__] that [__] I don't have time
for that stuff anymore I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're newer to the channel make sure
you hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out